another celebrity revealed on the masked
singer Tori was emotional after her
reveal you were my sentimental favorite
I love you so much and you had the most
heart being here tonight and I you
didn't please on previous weeks the
former 902 1o actress revealed she was
from Beverly Hills and her physical clue
from her final performance was her
father Aaron Spelling's famous
typewriter on which she wrote several of
his hit shows actually that's how he did
it it's old school but he started every
one of his scripts they're out forever
on that and then I got it when he passed
ken Jeong may not have guessed his very
own co-star Margaret Cho during last
week's reveal but he nailed this one
I've been thinking Tori Spelling this
whole time grew up like Beverly Hills
famous parent and like just kind of the
comeback then through a lot so you be
making sense right maybe although we'll
have to keep watching to find out who
the rest of the secret singing stars are
et caught up with panelist Nicole
Scherzinger ahead of Wednesday's episode
where she dished on the reveal people
have to remember that we get the clues
right in the moment so whenever we see
the packages it's right in the moment
now we see these physical clues it's
right in the moment so we don't have the
time to go online and Google things so I
will tell you I was shocked by last
week's reveal none of us had any idea
that was Margaret Cho you never know
until they're revealed my biggest shock
and I think everyone's biggest shock was
who actually ends up winning the show
[Music]
you